everybody welcome back I'm standing in
between Phil and Andrea they're about
ready to do their debt free scream I can
see it in their eyes I can see it from
their perspective
Dave's about ready I just freaked him
out in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
Phil and Andrea are with us hey guys
welcome thank you thank you
where you guys from North Canton Ohio
North Canton Ohio well welcome to
Nashville no wooden door I look up in
Ken Coleman the he's the emcee for our
TV program the host of our television
program that airs at Dave Ramsey calm or
if you get your ramsey app and he's like
messing with you all right before we
come on like you're not nervous enough
being on the radio so you just give the
word while firing oh my gosh you guys
know Kanter is he just being abusive in
general yeah okay is he trying to get
you to relax maybe all right cool it's
not working I love it
so you're here to do your debt-free
scream how much have you paid off
$85,000 $85,000
love that and I'm making what kind of
money during that 18 months we started
at 90,000 and ended at 150 that's a
little jump what happened to your income
well actually
uncle had taken a sabbatical year mm-hmm
and I had increased my hours to make up
the difference
and during us paying off our debt he
started back to work oh okay so the
increased hours come back now I got it
okay so that's not your you probably
will decrease the hours a little now yes
what do you do for a living I'm a nurse
practitioner okay and I'm a pastor okay
thus the sabbatical okay a whole year oh
yeah Wow very cool how long have you
been pastoring um eight years how often
do you take a year they tell us to take
about one year every six or seven years
servus okay so that's about it okay and
what background our denomination is that
United Methodist no cool okay good good
my great-great-great maybe grandfather
was a United Methodist United Brethren
which later split with the Methodists
and became but he was a circuit riding
preacher for the Methodists ah very cool
well congratulations you guys what kind
of debt is this eighty five thousand two
vehicles school loan and about three
thousand dollars on a credit card
Graham alone and the grandma mode oh the
grandma okay and how much how much did
you owe Gregg grandma about about ten
thousand dollars okay all right and how
long have you guys been married 15 years
okay so what happened eighteen months
ago that after 15 years set you guys on
fire cuz this is amazing how much you
paid off yeah when I was on my
sabbatical we had to be connected to
another you know Methodist Church during
that time period and they were offering
it and me having a undergraduate called
the Financial Peace University class yes
okay
and me being connected with my history I
had a degree in finance and so I ended
up saying yes let's take this class
after she we still debate Hugh you who
had the idea but we ended up taking the
class I believe it was her idea yeah I
think it was and so we ended up taking a
class and I'll never forget sitting in
the class in the second week after
reading all the book and realizing that
I was robbing my children of their
future and onion and I became very angry
at myself because I believed I had
everything under control I would put
everything on a credit card every month
but pay it off and I was playing this
game that I wasn't winning and I wanted
a future from my family and so that's
really what put me on fire and I just
really just made a decision never ever
ever again never so Andrea you guys get
in the
laughs and this guy turns into the
financial Hulk yes I mean he's like
pinch Emil turn Green Man he's gone he
was he's like we're doing this we're
doing this now yeah and and were you an
agreement or how'd it go yeah yeah I've
always wanted to get rid of our student
loans if they didn't like a stressor for
me remember since we got married and he
was like oh so you're like it's just
this is this is my man yeah that was
really excited yeah so as soon as he was
ready to go I was ready to go and we
just we sat down and did our budget and
we just went so and when we first get
and when we first got married she was
the one that wanted to get rid of the
debt I having the background said no
we're okay that way Rhett and to the men
that are out there listen to your why so
Andrea talk about this because there's
so many people call me and say well I
can't get my spouse on board I can't get
myself on board that wasn't the case
with you guys yeah but you still had
this moment where you guys are driving
home from the class one night and Phil
suddenly has lit up like a light bulb
and talked about as a wife who was
already wanting to do this stuff when
the spouse got on board and got all the
way on board how that felt for you
towards him well I was actually just so
excited and it was amazing to sit down
and do our budget and just the
communication there it was really just
opened up a whole another section of our
marriage with like being able to talk
like so freely about you know what do we
want to do here and what do we want to
do there because the money affects
everything so you know you have to make
those decisions you can't just go to an
event or do this or do that without
deciding financially about it so it kind
of just it just encouraged our whole
marriage I feel and we were able to
actually actually sat down into budget
meetings weekly which was so fun and we
just really I thought it helped us
become like a better stronger couple
actually yeah but when he flips and says
we're gonna do this and he's leading out
there and he's going yeah you're you're
going I love this man that's a cool
moment
that's a cool moment
I've got an opportunity to experience
that with a lot of couples over the
years going through financial piece and
where it changes that dynamic in your
marriage
all because we got this subject of money
going yeah it's so cool to be on the
same page you know on that in that
respect finally it was like a really
neat feeling yeah cool cool so what was
the hardest thing you guys did to get
out of debt well one of the things that
I did is I ended up driving a very very
cheap Toyota Camry with a number of
dents in it and didn't have any air
conditioning and had over 200,000 miles
in it and I think probably the hardest
thing for us in the whole process was
just saying no especially to going out
to eat as a family because we were
working so many hours and I was working
even a part-time second job helping in
the high school area and just saying
just saying no we're gonna stay home
we're gonna commit to this tell every
dollar where it's going and to make sure
that we're on the same path did you sell
stuff oh yeah we had a number of garage
sales yeah anything big online no but we
did have to start with we had originally
done are withholding way off and so the
very first month that we started it was
amazing kind of we got nine thousand
dollar income tax return ah okay yeah so
boom that jump-started it was awesome
that cash flow helped you from there
that's very good yeah very good good so
as a minister now it puts you in a
completely different place preaching
because you're in control of your money
and you can speak gently with compassion
but with also with authority now into
this subject yes absolutely absolutely
and I was able to actually coordinate
the class at the church that I'm serving
and so I had a number of people in the
congregation that went through the class
also so it was really a great great time
and we ended up at the same time taking
the classic
for a second time just to make sure that
we're on focus and on fire and we do the
budget every month and want to make sure
we got steps 3 through you know 7 that
we were are still focused on that we're
headed in the right direction very cool
well and very cool all right
$85,000 paid off Callie Kirsten Cameron
Phil and Andrea in 18 months make it 90
up to 150 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream 3
I love it I love it I love it you guys
are awesome
very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim